[Music]
Ms Walden your son situation is very
serious
what up James you know that's a joke
he's a good cat he's suspended effective
immediately next time it will not be a
next time there were three of them
coming from you next more school or
juvenile hall you have got to choose
I will move heaven and earth for you to
go to private school you want to borrow
$7000 for school I'm a COBOL you go rob
a bank
you just don't qualify my son can't wait
come work for me I'll look you up
he needs change today not tomorrow not
next week
and definitely not eventually we've been
waiting I'm done
so when you say I say a lot of things
I'm a politician to what you did so that
low-income students could go to private
schools well I want to do that here you
have a better chance of winning the
lottery than getting that done on behalf
of the parents of Washington DC and
present this petition and the rules are
clear sir to home this is a movement
hanging this is the salary ratio please
join me in welcoming fortune Walden you
might just be formidable you are going
to do right by the thousands of kids in
washington d.c wall that miss Townsend
I have to sue
so you cannot be will not deny our
children their right tomorrow
you